my name is jose posada i'm colombian i'm
from south america
so recently i have transitioned into
this thing called constraint
optimization so you want to train your
fancy neural network to do certain
things but you want to force it to have
certain kinds of behavior so you want to
enforce certain constraints onto the
model to to act in a certain way and
there are specific optimization
techniques to drive the model not just
to have super good performance but also
to to balance different kinds of
constraints or behaviors that you want
to include that you already knew
beforehand
oh i get maybe jose in wonderland
it'd be
it's i mean it's a great opportunity to
be to be doing research at mila and i
feel like i have a lot of freedom to
explore uh very interesting topics and
at least i've had the kind of the
independence and the freedom to move
around different things so yeah it's
like wonderland to be to be doing such
amazing research here
when i was doing my master's degree i
was working on something called manifold
learning or like geomet geometry and
deep learning and
i was reading a lot of papers from
joshua and pascal and so
like it felt like a very natural fit to
to apply to to be supervised by them
eventually it turns out that joshua was
busy taking other students and pascal
had transitioned to industry so i had
the the amazing opportunity to be paired
with with simone la corgilliere which
has been just a wonderful threat for my
research
montreal is as
interesting so i used to be i used to
live in amsterdam before so it's a very
different style of city the winter and
the like big streets and big buildings
is very it's very different uh
i like that there's a lot of
of uh like latino people here so it's
it's easy for me let's say to go to a
latino supermarket and get and get like
ingredients to cook my own stuff so i
like that a lot i cook arepas i don't
know if you have ever known apples like
little pancakes made out of corn they're
they're really nice to make for like a
breakfast or like a late midnight snack
you just put some flour and you put
water and then you put them on a grill
they're yummy with cheese
[Music]
if you want something done give it to
someone busy
so
like i understand keeping a healthy
work-life balance is important but also
like it's i feel it more about being on
a state of focus and like committing to
your ideas and when you have like
integrated people on a project it's easy
to just like gain from that momentum and
just keep going and when you have kind
of assemble a team and you are focused
on a goal it like you get more tasks
your team and it's easier to kind of
tackle those challenges